what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here Andrew here I am so excited this is
the one III trailer I want to be on top
of as possible right now and that is the
Last of Us part 2 e through 2018
gameplay reveal trailer as we're
shooting this it dropped 1 minute ago
this year I officially got back into
actual gaming and it started with the
Last of Us I would move first time in
years I was hooked on a game and all I
wanted to do was play it loved every
moment of it I am so excited for this
right now I'm like super super excited
her last time we did a video of it I
hadn't played it yet alright you ready
to get to it buddy
let's do is check out the gameplay
without one night to make a little brown
damn it little said he had a shot or
down went back home jumped into bed 45
pistol under my
[Music]
[Music]
I have told you amazing graphics what's
crazy
[Music]
when I hate these things tell me about
it
your old man really laid into me today
what happened
another big lecture about my patrols
don't go here don't go there
it's funny how involved he gets whenever
you're scheduled to go out yeah
she's a but not quite the show
[Music]
there's a lot more ethnicities two weeks
back together
not gonna happen she say something dude
make it one week
really hey what took you so long
boom here and I Deena Jesse hey don't
forget we leave first light to get some
rest
yes sir yeah yeah such a day come on
don't you start with me okay I have a
very serious question for you how bad do
I smell a hot pile of garbage
oh okay yeah you love it
[Music]
every guy in this room is staring at
here right now you got your big cat
what's her I mean they're staring at you
make out do it or not
maybe they're jealous of you
[Music]
just a girl matheran
[Music]
I think they should be terrified
[Music]
his eyes are wide open
oh no where's the asian guy who wants
her back take no prisoners oh here we go
[Music]
can't believe this is game do wonder if
you're gonna play as Ellie more in this
one I love play zone intense part of the
first game yeah
so many children
Water Street
got how terrifying this
may she guide you watching assassin's
creed birthday spread out remember the
other trailer someone was being hung to
you
I love that in the game when you go
through like familiar parts like like a
garage but it's like a ruins of a garage
like this grass growing everywhere and
stuff love that
you got this alley you got this
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
she went into the grass that's right al
watch yourself kill burying women in the
first can now now you know yeah I know
yeah it's crazy to be watching some feel
like you're playing again well she came
through here double back so it guns the
camera works improved yeah like it's a
lot more long hand combat yeah way
better
it's like a lot more action movie
cinematic angle yeah with when it comes
to the following the movement
[Music]
Wow Oh tail I was wondering I thought
the arrow disappear yeah oh she has been
doing that listening stuff you know when
you listen ya laters just really good at
the game so maybe you have to do the
same thing here that's so scary dude
though how the room is lit
I'm so impressed with the camera work
it's way better it was like the rate of
the first time buddy blood which yeah
it's like the details
they may get a health kit no just that
one there you go good job explosive
arrow is how with that said is that what
it was I think it said explosive arrow I
rather were explosives
always
[Music]
can you feel it
Wow grab the arrows the arrows
[Music]
[Music]
well sever she was thinking about the
whole choose what I think about you when
they make it he should be terrified
[Music]
I am so jacked I'm not sure yet I'm sure
people let us know in the comments god I
was so into that it was so that 11
minutes flew right by man 1 minute
almost 12 that flew right by I was so
into that one thing the gameplay trailer
lost for more commentary throughout the
reaction so I feel like we said a lot of
what we were thinking the part that I
was so impressed with with this gameplay
trailer of what they decide to reveal
here it was all le they hint you know
it's like Joel still around you've seen
him in another trailer it was mentioned
here with whomever that Johnny is this
said your old man told me when it yeah
you have very protective over you or
something like that yeah see here there
but this whole trailer was very le
focused you only play as le for a small
part of the first game that was one of
the most intense parts of the game
especially because she was still a
rookie and so there's a lot of fear and
you're so invested in this story and now
that Ellie is a lot more advanced in her
skills it makes for a much more badass
dynamic cuz I feel like when you think
of the last of us gameplay you're gonna
want to see some footage or Joel and
then you get Ellie instead and it was
just as if not more rewarding I think
for sure I love the updates they've made
with the hand hand combat the camera
camera weren't easy is so much more
improved yeah that was one thing I
didn't even think they would try to do
you know one thing I really appreciate I
mean there's so much tension throughout
the thing because again how invested we
all are in Ellie but every time you
think she's safe there's another amount
of you know bad guys come and also I
like how there's so many different
escape routes that you can play you can
go under a car you can go through the
side of ya know cracks and name
exteriors you kind of like find your way
out of these messes
so I like that they're giving you like
fun puzzles solved while at the same
time giving you incredibly and in comic
when she did the explosive arrows I mean
yes I'm loving to the updates as I said
just explosive air ISM I'm so curious to
see what other updates they made with
the weaponry I mean when the camera
angle follows them around every motion
she's doing it the cameras smoothly
following her and knows when to crash
like a wall yeah it's like a beautiful
long shot that enhances the experience
every time
every movement she does if she's
striking or ducking or getting pulled in
the camera follows each one of those
movements it doesn't just stay
stationary and it doesn't just crash in
or zoom in or whatever when she's
getting hit or when she's hitting
someone
it follows every little detail the
camera angle will shift depending on the
intensity of the situation in that
action moment when I was watching this I
felt like I was playing the game again
I really felt like oh my god that's I
feel when I'm playing the actual game
sure and some people might disagree with
me but I wouldn't even mind seeing this
in movies the way this is like films
like no I've seen the longshots how
would just smoothly just move so in a
position to where you feel like you're
in total control but you're not at a bad
angle to where you feel like you're like
I can't see or I'm gonna get screwed
over there and someone's like kind of
blindsides you it's like it always feels
like you're at a proper angle like where
you need to be and the attention to
detail on the violence too like we
pointed out with the arrow being stuck
in her yeah a lot of games arrow would
just disappear or something but she went
on for a while and then she eventually
subs like pull it out that it find her
attention to detail and there's blood on
it also too if you notice she's gotten a
tattoo on her right forearm yeah I
definitely didn't have that in the first
game so obviously I mean I would imagine
this is a couple a few years later what
has to be several years like yeah I mean
she's obviously older matured I mean she
has it's like love romance yeah and also
they kind of pointed that in the first
game in terms of that there's like an
after after you beat the story mode
there's a mission that takes place
before you know she meets up with Joel
and all and the fireflies and all them
she does have a love interest that's a
girl her age so they actually did hint
at that you felt organic you know even
though we don't really you know know too
much about the story like just what we
did see it actually did feel organic and
I really like the chemistry between the
two of them all you have to tell me is
lots of us part two and I'm sold I don't
need to know more about the story I'll
find out when I'm there cuz I trust the
writers good I'll be like yeah I'm gonna
watch the store I play the whole game
yeah this was great this is fantastic
just take my money just take off yeah I
don't even care if I go in the negatives
I wouldn't even get the special special
edition or whatever I guess the next
question is you get to actually play as
Joel at some point or is he just way too
old to play as now might even be like
reduced like how much Ellie was played
in the first game maybe that's how much
maybe they flip it yeah we're now flyby
well with everyone though
plain is Joel free awesome yeah there's
gonna be plenty of Joel alright guys
what do you think of this gameplay
trailer how awesome does it look to you
guys I'm excited as hell for it you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons are kind of broken you could
check out and zero on the movie source
channel a lot of great movie coverage
over there follow me egg or 7-eleven on
twitter and check out our patreon full
like TV show reactions weekly Q&A s
music video coverage would love to have
you become a patron eject today